news the doses of the johnson and
johnson vaccine are heading back
into the arms of americans after federal
health officials
lifted their 10-day pause on friday
concerns were raised after 15 rare blood
clotting incidents were discovered in
women
who would receive the vaccine this says
more than
41 percent of americans have received at
least one shot of a coronavirus vaccine
and more than one quarter of the adults
in this country now fully
vaccinated michael george begins our
coverage michael good morning
jeff good morning you know it's never
been easier to get a vaccine at sites
like this one
now in new york anyone over 16 can just
walk in and get a vaccine
no appointment needed and in some parts
of the country vaccine supplies are now
outpacing demand
as the focus now is on convincing those
who are vaccine hesitant
after the cdc cleared the way for
johnson and johnson's vaccine yesterday
afternoon
so the vote is 10
in favor four opposed
and one abstention health officials with
stockpiles
this one in texas were ready though the
j and j
vaccine may come with a warning alerting
women about a possible risk of rare
blood clots
cdc scientists found the benefits
outweigh the possible risk
statistically 26 to as many as 45 adults
might get a blood clot
but up to 1400 lives might be saved
while covid rates are no longer on the
rise the pandemic is still
a crisis in this country overall we're
fairly flat but we're flat with 60 000
new cases a day
we're flat with 700 deaths a day so it's
not like we're in a particularly great
place
so the push is on to vaccinate several
baton rouge college bars teamed up with
health care workers to vaccinate student
regulars
having it here pulls in the younger
crowd especially they're also doing like
we get like free no cover cards and so i
feel like you're definitely getting like
a two for one by coming here
the pressure to vaccinate was also
center court for the first time
at last night's golden state warriors
basketball game in san francisco
fans had to prove they'd been vaccinated
or had a negative covet test
to enter the chase center
[Music]
and that'll be true for more than a
million california public university
students
staff and faculty wanting to return to
campuses in the fall
the idea of vaccine passports is being
advocated by ucsf's dr bob wachter
and he's expecting controversy vaccine
passports or vaccine
authentication will be the the masks of
2021
but the problem is your vaccination
status affects your community
if more and more businesses start
requiring vaccinations for things like
travel or dining health experts say they
do expect a pushback from some similar
to what we saw
with masks michelle all right thank you
michael